♪ ♪
>> HE WAS THE NARRATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR ONE OF THE BIGGEST NAMES IN
UBISOFT HISTORY, FAR CRY 5 AND
HE'S HERE TO REVEALL THE NEXTCH.
PLEASE WELCO JOHN SEBASTIAN TO
DECANTE.
♪ ♪
>> HELLO EVERYONE.
AS YOU MAY REMEMBER, FAR CRY
CRY 5 WAS NUKES DROPPING ON
MONTANA, AND THIS MONTH IS THE
VERY BEGINNING OA BRAND-NEW
WORLD.
AS THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR OF THIS
NEW PROJECT, IT IMY ABSOLUTE
PRESSURE TO REVEAL TO Y FAR
CRY: NEO DAWN.
♪ ♪
>> WE WERE JUST T KIDS WHEN THE
BOMBS DROPPED IN THE WORLD WENT
SHIT TO.
THEY SAID IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE END OF EVERYTHING..
BUT FOR US, IT WAS JUST THE
BEGINNINGG.
SURVIVING?
NO.
WE WERE BETTER THAN THAT.
THIS NEW WORLD HAD A LOT TO GIVE
AND WE TOOK IT ALL.
THAT'S HOW WE CAME OUTUT ON TOP.
THAT'S HOW WE GOT HERE.
THAT'S HOW WE FOUND YOU.
LISTEN HERE, RABBITS!
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND SOMETHIN
SOMETHING.
THE ONLY CURRENCY LEFT IN THIS
WORLD IS POWER.
WE ARERE GOING TO TAKE EVERYTHIG
FROM YOU, STARTING WITH YOUR
HOME.
IF WE CAN'T TAKE IT...
WE'LL BREAK IT.
♪ ♪
>> I LED US INTO THE NEW WORLD,
I THOUGHT THAT IT WOULD BE
GLORIOUS.
IAS WRONG.
♪